Er muss schnell her, der Impfstoff gegen das
Virus.
Normalerweise dauert es mehrere Jahre,
einen Impfstoff zu entwickeln.
Doch weil die Zeit drängt,
sollen die sechs notwendigen
Entwicklungsphasen
nun in ein paar Monaten durchlaufen werden.
Zuerst analysieren Forscher das Virus.
Aus Bestandteilen des Virus und
Zusatzstoffen
entwickeln sie einen möglichen Impfstoff.
Im dritten Schritt wird dieser an Tieren
erprobt,
im vierten dann an Menschen.
Dann müssen die Behörden den Stoff
genehmigen,
bevor er letztlich in die Massenproduktion
geht.
Mehr als 70 Impfstoffprojekte versuchen
Wissenschaftler gerade,
so schnell wie möglich durch diesen
Prozess zu schicken.
Einige Forscher sind schon in Phase 4, testen
ihren Impfstoff also bereits an Freiwilligen.
Doch Experten rechnen damit, dass es
mindestens ein Jahr dauern wird,
bis eine Impfung breit verfügbar ist.
Forscher versuchen auf unterschiedliche
Arten, an einen Impfstoff zu kommen:
In Versuchen mit Lebendimpfstoffen
setzen sie auf bereits bekannte harmlose
Viren, sogenannte Vektorviren.
Ihnen wird ein Teil des Erbguts des
Sars-CoV2-Erregers eingeschleust.
Die Folge:
Sie bilden dieselben Oberflächenproteine wie
das Coronavirus.
Dieses „verkleidete“ Virus kann im Menschen
keinen Schaden anrichten,
aber das Immunsystem des Geimpften
reagiert trotzdem darauf und bildet Antikörper.
Nun wüsste der Körper, wie er sich gegen das
echte Virus schützen kann.
Andere forschen mit Totimpfstoffen, also mit
abgetöteten Teilen des Coronavirus.
So werden auch andere Impfstoffe, etwa
gegen Tetanus oder Grippe, hergestellt.
Allerdings könnte es mit dieser Methode
schwierig werden,
schnell große Mengen herzustellen.
Die neueste Entwicklung: genbasierte
Impfstoffe.
Dafür wird dem Virus sogenannte RNA
entnommen, seine genetische Bauanleitung.
Ein damit hergestellter Impfstoff ruft im Körper
die Bildung von Virusproteinen hervor,
und das Immunsystem reagiert mit
Antikörpern.
Aber:
Es gibt noch keinen einzigen zugelassenen
Impfstoff dieser Art.
Jetzt in der Krise hoffen viele:
Es muss doch bald mal einen Impfstoff
geben!
Doch selbst wenn er da ist, heißt das nicht,
dass die Pandemie vorbei ist.
Das Virus könnte mutieren, sich genetisch
verändern.
Bereits erfolgreich getestete Impfstoffe
könnten dann plötzlich wirkungslos sein.
Gegen Grippeviren zum Beispiel muss jedes
Jahr ein neuer Impfstoff entwickelt werden.
Und auch bereits bekannte Coronaviren
neigen dazu, ihre DNA zu verändern.
Bisher ist der Covid-19-Erreger während
seiner weltweiten Verbreitung kaum mutiert.
Und doch bleibt es ein Rennen gegen die
Zeit:
Je schneller ein Impfstoff kommt,
desto mehr Menschen können geschützt
und somit auch gerettet werden.